welcome to CBS this morning and we begin
with this president Trump gave himself a
glowing review of his three years in
office and last night's State of the
Union address the tensions with the
Democrat who green-lighted his
impeachment were very visible to
everyone House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
literally torqued the President's speech
at the end of a remarkable night the
president did not mention his
impeachment in his address he listed a
long string of achievements that made
his fellow Republicans stand up and roar
their approval he also made his guests a
big part of the speech weecha jiang is
at the White House we should have the
president stay on message
good morning Anthony yes president Trump
stuck to his script laying out what he
believes are his greatest
accomplishments and making the case for
another four years it was a political
speech delivered in a divisive
environment that was impossible to
ignore the tension between President
Trump and House Speaker Nancy Pelosi was
on display from the beginning when the
president appeared to snub policies
handshake and she left out the customary
high privilege and distinct honor when
introducing mr. Trump members of
Congress the President of the United
States and while President Trump stayed
focused on expected policy topics
jobs are booming incomes are soaring
poverty is plummeting 2.2 trillion
dollars in the United States military
the bloodthirsty killer known as
al-baghdadi is dead there were subtle
made-for-tv moments throughout the
evening
awarding a scholarship for a young high
school student you will soon be heading
to the school of your choice the
Presidential Medal of Freedom to
conservative radio host Rush Limbaugh he
is here with us tonight
[Applause]
and setting up a reunion between a
deployed service member and his family
that drew a rare bipartisan applause but
throughout the night Speaker Pelosi
visibly expressed her disapproval of
several of the president's claims
including this one about health care we
will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
the Trump administration has argued in
court that all of the Affordable Care
Act should be invalidated including its
protections for pre-existing conditions
governor Gretchen Whitmer of Michigan a
state mr. Trump barely won in 2016
struck back as she delivered the
official Democratic response Democrats
are trying to make your health care
better Republicans in Washington are
trying to take it away but the
unofficial response came from speaker
Pelosi who stood up and ripped president
Trump's speech the minute he was done
Republicans criticized Pelosi for being
Petty and lacking bipartisanship so far
she hasn't shown an interest in working
after the speech speaker Pelosi called
the address a quote manifesto of
mistruths the White House hit back
accusing her of ripping up the guest of
honor and claiming that is her legacy
Tony all right we should thank you very
much